The Joe Rogan experience
and I'm getting less.
He carried a deer's out every
time I see that now be thinking,
how do you carry the deer,
nick?
If he did,
he'd never tell anybody he would have
Lyme disease and just run 150 miles and
still alive disease died out.
You man, he's a psycho II. You,
there's discipline and then this is what
that guy has. And this guy too though.
Y'all Goggins he's another one man.
He's another one.
It's like these guys that like,
they,
they exhibit this next level toughness
that makes you reexamine what you're
doing.
Like you think you tough and then you
find out what Goggins what do we say?
He'd ran like 28 100
fucking mile runs in a row.
Something insane like that.
More than once. A lot. Why?
Because when you run over two miles,
I'll look like why I get a text message
from Goggins say stay hard, motherfucker.
This is, I'm checking in on
you right now. Can you see,
you see [inaudible] you hear them yelling
in the texts. Have you seen the, um,
can we go, uh, Netflix losers? No, I
haven't. Oh look it up. It's one on there.
Uh, the guy called lost in the desert.
It's a guy who runs, that's a desert ruin.
They do carry on what country? But he'd
go out there and he was just so mad,
so obsessed with winning like thousands
of people running through the desert.
But it's, of course they have
to follow when the wind get bad.
They got checking ins and whatnot they
supposed to follow and he said he was so
obsessed,
like he wasn't checking.
He was like trying to take shortcuts
and like if I go this way, I'll find it.
He ended up going off the course and when
it cleared up, he was way off course.
But he was so obsessed.
I still gotta finish.
He was out there for like five or
something. Five or six days. Yeah.
And that's talking about how they
announced to his family, told his family,
your husband's dead. We
can't find you. Find them.
They had helicopters
going all over the place.
He went to the point where he
starts drinking his own piss.
He found his cave was full of
Battlestar [inaudible] ripping his off,
mixing them up the trigger
to survive, drinking the Batu
strategies, mixing it up,
and he like, at one point I
heard the helicopter coming over.
He took all his clothes, all his
geared, dug a hole and set it on fire,
hoping they would see
him at the fire one up.
The wind blew it out so he didn't get
sick. So he out there with no gear,
no nothing in the middle of nowhere.
He's a vile.
He ended up getting back in his mind.
He's everybody left.
He said when he got there,
the checkpoint was gone,
but his friend had flew back to find them
and sure enough his friend was there,
found them in a desert. Yeah, it's called.
Those are the documents
called losers here.
Losers in the episode is lost in
the desert. The whole show is good.
All the little things on it was good,
but that lost in the desert.
He ended up divorcing.
His wife was wife left him because
after that he still went back.
He came home and she was like, you're not
going back. And like, I'm doing it again.
I have to finish and now he still does.
He divorced his wife.
His wife left when his wife left
him because you've got a family.
When she left and he left, she was
mad like, what about your family?
People die on this. What
happened? He's like, don't worry.
This is miss. I love this.
I have to do it.
When he came back and his wife was like,
we're not doing it again. He was like,
yes, I am like you. Just as on like,
he was pretty much dead.
They put him in the hospital.
They found them and everything. She
ended up doing again. Mauro prosperity.
Wow.
The survival story of moral
Prospera disoriented after a turns.
Sahara desert does.
Italian ultra marathon runner
walk nearly 200 miles to safety,
but he's Italian. He's probably
going to get divorced anyway. Hey,
what am I gonna go?
Well was it was fucking guys
are animals. Yeah. You see it.
You're going to be like, I have to. I want
you to direct DME after you watched it.
I'll see it. When he ate the badges, I was
like that. I was just kill myself there.
I'm not like, he was really biting their
heads off. Just any dark, no light.
He could. He was feeling phone.
He can see the odd, he gra
he was survive. Kate, what kind
of diarrhea did that guy have? Oh,
kill drinking. Dot. Even killed. He
tried to kill this stuff actually,
but he was so dehydrated.
He cut his wrist because they had the
last thing he cut his wrists with and went
to bed hoping he's going to wait,
like not wake up debt and he woke up.
He was like, what in the world? He said,
and that was my sign that
I wasn't supposed to die.
He said when he got the house,
when he saw his Bris,
they said you were to die dehydrated
to believe. So he didn't have anything.
He couldn't believe he's healed Jesus
Christ. That was it. He was, while he's,
I felt myself fainting. I
just kept telling myself,
I'm here. I have to make it.
I have to make it and I have to make it,
and he said he finally like he see like
some girl walking out in the desert.
He started walking away. She was
going and then the army, whatever,
wherever they was at the army had to
come get him and they got guns and shit.
You think he's going to die? Ended up
taking him to the house. When he woke up,
he had ivs and everything and they were
covering him and took him back to his
family. It's a crazy story.
I mean all of them was good,
but that was my brother calling
me. Like, watch that Bro.
You got a mentality like that.
You ought to fucking man washed
that two days and he stumbled into an
abandoned Muslim shrine where he noticed
some bats huddled together.
Prosperity, grabbed a handful of them,
cut off their heads with a knife and
then sucked out their insides to drink
their blood and quenching thirst.
Eventually he did his Vampire Act on 20
bats when another three days pass with
no signs of rescue.
He slit his wrists and waited to die,
but his blood thick and due to
dehydration so it wouldn't drain out.
Fuck man.
Like that's some Goggins and county to
get together and do a podcast and talking
about that,
like that was,
they wouldn't have cut their wrist
[inaudible] killed himself.
It would have just kept going.
I think those,
those kinds of people is ultra
marathon people. It's a different,
different breed of human. You know,
they, it's like everything has,
there's levels right to everything.
There's levels you, you've,
you've experienced it in your
own life where you tough adopt,
it became a stronger person, a harder
person. And then there's levels past that.
And then there's levels past that.
And especially for people
that have one solitary thing,
they do like ultra marathons there, all
the skinny dudes who can just keep going,
keep going. It's just, it's,
it's the, the pulling it off the,
crossing the line and knowing that
you did something that seemed almost
impossible. So, so titanic, Lee,
epically difficult to do that. So few
people can ever do it. When they do,
they're talking about running a 500 mile
race now cause they did the Moab to 30
and they had the big foot 200 they'll all
these people that are putting on these
races, they were like, okay,
we could do to 40 let's see if we can do
500 so now they're talking about doing
a 500 mile race.
It's next level.
It was hard for me to run a five K I
hearing when you're a big fellow too.
I mean I could do it,
but I did in college and I've never ran
like nothing calculated like you had to
pay do again. It was like a charity we
had to do for college. Nope. Never again.
Have you ever thought about
doing something like that?
Like I'm gonna go around from
five k I ain't going to pay.
It's like going Scott,
I want my jump out of a perfectly
good plane to go on the ground play,
pay to run a five k like
what did the organizing it?
I guess most of them I go to foundations
and stuff like that. But even then,
like you heard about the foundation that
taking money and what you do hear about
paying no punting something books
to go run 13.1 miles. Right. Cool.
People, it's more the fact that I can say
I did it. I can see I did it on my own.
I run 13.1 miles and not check my
phone. 13 miles. We're good. Yeah,
I'm home.